it's Friday the 24th I'm rob with a
different approach to this week's top 5
news stories I popped a sixty-dollar
version of rocket League on Steam and
have three codes to give earlier this
morning I asked people to send in your
guesses on what stories will pitch the
first three people with the closest
answers will get rocket League let's get
right to it everyone ready all right
first up 09 as in owning up to mighty
number nine mighty number nine creator
Keiji Inafune a has taken responsibility
for the game's quality and issues
Inafune a says that he owns all of the
problems that came with the game further
saying and if you want to hurl the
insults at me it's totally my fault the
problems included Kickstarter back name
codes failing to work visual issues and
overall quality of the gameplay some
good news though if you happen to be one
of these 70,000 Kickstarter backers you
made it into the four hour long credit
roll at the end of the game oh dang I
know that guys are we ready for the next
one guys clips into it okay next one
here is 0 2 as an oculus has stopped
blocking the vibe after the oculus rift
was released it wasn't long before
revived a way to run its exclusive games
on the HTC vive was created oculus
responded by requiring a hardware check
as part of its drm but now the company
has removed this check much to the
revived creator surprise oculus has
confirmed the move with verge further
stating we believe protecting developer
content is critical to the long-term
success of the VR industry and will
continue taking steps in the future to
ensure that VR developers can keep
investing in groundbreaking new VR
content okie dokie artichokie let's take
a look at the next one
but we got a winner g8 as in great news
the steam summer sale is here there's a
heat wave going on my feet are sore
there's a stalker outside who wants to
wear my skin find your own excuse to
stay inside because today's deals are
hot like super hot twenty bucks alien
isolation twelve dollars work or how
about the entire Sniper Elite trilogy
420 clams hot hot hot hot hot hot this
steam summer sale runs now until the
fourth of July next one here is Cheryl
eyes on me g-10 as in greens be coming
to 10 million ps3 owners Sony's six year
long class action lawsuit related to the
ps3 is wrapping up back in 2010 Sony
locked out support for users who wish to
run linux on their ps3 s many people
were super pissed in terms of the
settlement which has not been approved
sony has agreed to pay as much as fifty
five dollars to as many as 10 million
ps3 owners alright last one
okay what do we have here CCTV PLL Oh
8.6 as in clash of clans dev bought out
by league legends owner Oh bingo Edward
my man come on down bingo is right the
Chinese Internet company 10-cent who
owns a controlling interest in League of
Legends will pay 8.6 billion to acquire
880 4.3 percent stake in supercell
supercell is the developer of clash of
clans is now valued at ten point two
billion dollars Tencent has explained
that super cells existing management
would maintain operational independence
clash of clans has over 100 million
people playing each day in 2015 it was
the second highest-grossing digital
video game and to all of you real
winners out there you'll be getting a
code from me shortly thanks for playing
have a great weekend